je fais preuve du contraire c'est la
famille la phantom ans les frères
baillargeon sont la fierté de saint
magloire un terrible petit village de
750 habitants située dans la région
chaudière appalaches
doté d'une force herculéenne les six
frères vont frapper l'imaginaire des
gens au début du 20e siècle
alors monsieur lévesque c'était qui
cette famille étrange qu'on appelle les
bayards gens c'est une famille qui ont
fait leur marque
c'est une famille vraiment spécial parce
que voyez-vous ce confort et qui ont
accepté le fait des tours de force
ensemble un peu partout en amérique
avant d'aller dans le domaine de la
dette grecque faisait des démonstrations
de force dans les centres dans des
parois lisses leur laisser c'est à
l'orangé comme comme des soldats le lien
vital et invite allemande seuil est
l'heure pour que mon triste a pas de
stade du moustoir lost a vraiment quand
même et à 4 à l'ista vraiment 400 m
haies en jamais été battu la peinture
yeux de mon père c'est son éligibilité
s'il était plus ou moins gros que les
autres mais plus élancée et j'étais tout
agir la part de s'entraîner c'était à
une sautée seca aubert derrier lui sa
spécialité c'est une planche avec 18
personnes dessus
d'après ce que j'ai eus continue sa
baisse vu personne de supplice mettant
trop de la plateforme pied levé
bon donc charles lui c'est un tirage de
l'autre bus avec ses d'un paul uys état
de vue de comme d'une paroisse tantôt de
cheval d'un poteau à 98 lionel
laverdière se souvient très bien de ce
tour de force car c'était son cheval
qu'on soulevait le cheval que paul a
monté d'un poteau
c'est à mon cheval beaucoup disaient que
ça se monte à peau d'un effet un cheval
du il a menti
non j'avais lui ça du 320 livres sont
sous l eau potable
ce sera une nouvelle à bruxelles dès le
dépôt des haltères sauce incroyable où
ces phénomènes voudra voir la personne
pour vraiment contrastée la force énorme
que scolaire un phénomène certes mais
également un physique hors du commun
je l'essayé et je suis loin de gens là
je pense que j'aurais pu faire nous font
[Musique]
[Rires]
la force d'un imposant parce qu'elle
aussi est un l'enseigné puis quand il va
déclare aussi difficile dure là il ya la
chercher madame b argent
aurore guillemette ménard qui a vu
grandir les frères baillargeon confié
qu'au départ il n'était pas destiné à
faire le tour du monde avec leurs forces
et jean-jacques d accompagner ces
données et prêchant dans le petit
village de saint magloire une vieille
maison ancestrale vous attend elle
renferme tous les souvenirs de cette
famille exceptionnelle un héritage
inestimable
réunis par un groupe de bénévoles qui ne
veulent surtout pas on oublie les frères
baillargeon robert frosi radio-canada ça
ma gloire